sie werden es nicht glauben aber da tun
sich extreme Parallelen auf ich erkläre
sie ihnen der Liebling der Grünen Robert
Habeck und nicht nur der Grünen
Mitglieder sondern der gesamten
Wählerschaft volksnahrscheinbar
authentisch barfuß am Strand entlang zu
gehen nicht im Politik sprechen sondern
wie Menschen von der Sprache einfach ein
politischer Freigeist
der FC Bayern München
Lebensmittelpunkt für fast 300.000
Mitglieder der größte Sportverein der
Welt aber auch Herzensverein für
Millionen von Fußballfans in Deutschland
und in der ganzen Welt
volksnah ein Verein zum Anfassen
hilfsbereit
benefiz-spiele für ins Straucheln gerade
eine Vereine wie gesagt pauli Darmstadt
und das lässt sich unendlich fortführen
und die deutsche Mannschaft die nicht
nur in den letzten 10 Jahren für
internationales Ansehen des gesamten
deutschen Fußballs gesorgt hat
Robert Habeck und jetzt geht's langsam
runter die Kurve steht nach internen
Partei schmutzigen und Untergrund
kämpfen gegeneinander bärbock an der
Spitze der grünen Bewegung unser aller
Robert steht auch an der Spitze der
beliebtheitskala alle Politiker
erscheint
auch übers Wasser gehen zu können das
Problem dabei ist er glaubt selbst
langsam daran FC Bayern nachdem die
Bayern endgültig 2013 den Dortmundern
die kurze Vorherrschaft in der
Bundesliga wieder abgenommen haben
werden sie 10 Jahre in Folge Deutscher
Meister gewinnt zweimal die Champions
League werden auch Pokalsieger aber das
zählt schon gar nicht mehr sie sind das
absolute Maß aller Dinge in deutschen
Fußball auch in Europa und bei solchen
Erfolgen kannst du eigentlich nicht viel
falsch gemacht haben
die Rekordzahlen im sportlichen Bereich
ohne wirtschaftlichen Bereich es läuft
Robert Habeck um seine Macht und
Einfluss zu sichern bugsiert habe ich
einige Freunde Verwandtschaft und gute
Bekannte in Schlüsselpositionen seines
macht bereits
familiäres Blut ist dicke sagt man und
die Gehaltsschecks auch was sollen da
einige Warnungen aus der Partei
weggewischt der FC Bayern die Macher und
Väter diese Volks kann der Rummenigge
und Uli Hoeneß wollen das Haus des FC
Bayern bestellen sie wollen sich
zurückziehen es soll an Bewerber gehen
die das sogenannte Bayern gehen im Blut
haben dieses mir san mir verinnerlicht
haben kurz um es können nur ehemalige
Kicker in den roten Trikots sein die
Wahl fällt auf Oliver Kahn und Hassan
seine hamidzic sie werden internisiert
sie sind jetzt die neuen mache und
sie machen Fehler
das Ende naht Robert Habeck stürzt ab
seine Mausi line führt zu führen zu
einem Vertrauensverlust
Ausmaßes er ist plötzlich für die Grünen
bei Wahlen ein Malus robert ist toxisch
geworden
FC Bayern die neuen treffen mutige
Entscheidungen ich behaupte einige davon
waren übermütige Entscheidungen
Trainerentlassungen viel Einkäufe
kommunikationschaos das sind plötzlich
die neuen Themen an derselbener Straße
nicht mehr die sportlichen Erfolge sie
steuern auf die schlechteste Saison seit
Jahrzehnten zu Fazit es ist aber die
Frage
brauchen so eine Stunde Stunde
von Olaf Scholz der einen Machtwort
sprechen muss damit er seine Gesetze
endgültig durchbricht vielleicht auch
beschädigt und die Bayern brauchen die
Hilfe des FSV Mainz 05 bleibt die
logische Folge ist Olaf Scholz dass
Mainz 05 der Politik
sehr gut das war eine Rede von Waldemar
Hartmann und man hätte eigentlich diese
Sendung nicht besser beenden können ich
muss aber ich kann natürlich nicht gehen
wer wird mir jetzt also wer holt das
Ding wer wird jetzt Meister was ist
jetzt sehr also FC Bayern höre ich raus
äh leidet vielleicht ein bisschen an
Selbstüberschätzung sowie Robert habe
ich stand da so ein bisschen unterm
Strich naja bis jetzt ja klar aber man
hat sich erkannt wo es hingeht kurze
Antwort
nein das werden die Dortmunder also ähm
Markus Söder muss ich entschuldigen weil
der sagt dann warum die Dortmunder sie
zu dumm Deutscher Meister zu werden aber
Söder kann Bäume umarmen ähm kann
Bienenstöcke besuchen
oder so vielen herzlichen Dank
[Gelächter]